What are we making today?
Okay, so today, we're making strawberry lemon hand pies.
And what I love about these
is it is like this nostalgic thing.
There's something about these pies
that remind me of my childhood.
I can't wait for you to bite into them and see if-
Did you read this recipe? Did you make this recipe?
Did you have it in childhood? Did you find it somewhere?
Where is the origin?
So we have a little sweet truck at the Silos
that we call Maggie for short for Magnolia.
And that's our sweet truck.
And it's kind of this nostalgic food truck
that's got all these hand pies.
People could do this with their kids.
They could do this in the kitchen.
It's very simple.
Teach me.
And I'm all about desserts and food
that you can just get the basics
and then modify it however you like.
So we're doing strawberry and lemon,
but the sky's the limit on how you fill these things.
So you could do blueberry and Gruyere
if you were feeling it.
Anything you want, yes.
So today, we're gonna be doing strawberry lemon.
The first thing we're gonna make is the filling.
Okay.
Let's do this, so it's strawberries.
Depending on if strawberries are in season,
it's just two cups of whole strawberries
or two cups of frozen strawberries.
Just turn that up just a little bit.
Okay, so we're going to, these are frozen strawberries.
I thawed them just a little bit,
but you just wanna dump that into the pan.
What's the best way?
(strawberries sizzling)
Oh, yeah, baby.
Well, that was on and a little warm.
So let's just-
What's the best way
to thaw-
Cut that heat.
A frozen strawberry?
You just let 'em,
I just let them sit out for a second.
Okay, these are absolutely, the smell.
Whoa, that smell is so good.
Coming from here is so good.
So just stir that around.
We're gonna add 1/3 cup of the sugar.
Okay, add in this corn starch. It's two tablespoons.
And that's gonna be the thing that thickens this.
So there's a roux-
Yes.
Component.
And then as this gets warm,
we just wanna break down the strawberries
because, again, this is the filling,
so it's gonna be more like a jam or a jelly.
Mm.
So now that it's kinda bubbling up, we can cut the heat.
And now, look,
it's magically chilled and finished.
But this is our filling.
See? There I go.
This is the beauty, though.
This is the beauty.
There we go. Nothing to see here.
This is our little egg wash.
All right,
I see fork marks, too.
You ready?
Which I'm excited to do.
Yeah, this is fun.
So the dough's already been made,
but what I love about-
The dough has been made.
This dough is it's kind of your typical pie crust,
but it's, I've added eggs and a little milk
to make it a little more flaky.
So you can see
it's flakier.
I like flaky.
Yeah.
I want like a crescent roll.
Yes, so that egg is what makes it a little flakier.
So now the dough is one of those things
that would've taken an hour to chill,
so we just went ahead and did that.
It's done.
Okay, yup.
Magic of TV.
We are going to fill these little pies
with about a tablespoon of the filling.
Hold on. Let's brush those edges first.
So they don't, you know.
And just do one side.
So that's gonna be what seams them together.
So let's just brush the edge.
Just the edges?
Uh-huh.
Like sealing an envelope.
Yep, and you're just gonna do it on this top layer.
And then we're gonna fill on the inside
of that little border about a tablespoon.
What's a style you wanna bring back?
What's a style you want to go away?
That's a good question.
Let me fill my berries.
A style that I wanna bring back.
I think like, as I look at,
I have a bunch of old design books.
I don't even know.
I just love to open them up and see.
And I think what I love is that curiosity,
that, in some ways, that quirkiness, that randomness.
I feel like homes have just gotten so,
at least what we see-
They're very cookie-cutter.
A lot is it's very,
it's almost predictable now.
And I think it's like
let's bring back that unpredictability, you know?
And I think it's a balance of, for us, I work with clients.
And so at the end of the day,
I give the client what they want.
But the fun is in the,
especially the projects we get to do ourselves,
that it's just more like, hey, we're gonna sell this later,
so I can kinda just be as wild as I want.
Watch what I'm doing here.
Just pushing down and you just pull out like that.
You wanna just make sure, Drew,
that that filling doesn't ooze out.
So by sealing this
with that egg wash.
Yeah.
Pat, pat, pat.
Okay, so look.
We're gonna just give this a cutie little border.
Uh-oh, I'm oozing, Jo.
It's okay.
Go like this really quick. Boop.
Just do like four and that just allows the filling
to breathe when you have it in.
Okay, what's your happily ever after?
Oh.
I think we always say this.
We're like that we're sitting on that same porch
in those rocking chairs watching the sun go down
and say we did it well.
All our kids off and gone in a really healthy good way,
but saying we did it well.
That's it. It's very simple.
And you deserve that.
But we're still
holding hands and we still really like each other.
(chuckles) Please, God.
Oh, God.
Ugh. See?
I'm so aggressively single, but when I'm around you
and Chip,
(Joanna laughs)
it makes me go, I gotta,
maybe I should spreadage my wingage.
Spreadage your wingage.
Like he still says I love you
all the time.
Oh.
Kisses and I love you? (gasps)
Can he teach men?
He really is...
I'm like, "You need to just write a book
on how to treat a woman.
I mean, he's just so-
And put a real sexy picture
of yourself on the cover?
Good, yeah, well,
let's just use that same cover.
It's like thirst trap.
(both laughing)
Chip Gaines for thirst trap.
He would love that.
He's just a doll. He's sweet.
(upbeat pop music)